today we're unboxing the brand-new a
macbook pro 13 inch this was just
recently announced by Apple and we have
one here to check out this has the 10th
gen Core i5 processor whereas the lower
end starting price at $12.99 model only
has the 8th gen so the lower end models
are very similar to specs as the
previous 13-inch MacBook but it does
have double the storage and also giving
magic keyboard you can now max up the
internal storage to 4 terabytes so if
you are looking for an upgrade and an
entry-level computer there's a lot of
options right now on Apple's website I'm
pretty excited about this because I've
actually never reviewed one of the
13-inch MacBook s' so this is something
that is pretty exciting I've obviously
checked out the MacBook Airs I have one
of the 16 inch MacBook Pros that I used
to use when I travel it and left the
house but I am very excited to check
this out this is the 2 gigahertz
quad-core 1/10 Gen Intel Core i5 version
it has 16 gigs of RAM 512 gigabytes and
of course that new updated magic
keyboard look at you get you there
should smell there's no smell are you
okay wow this is awesome this is crazy
cuz I really have never truly I don't
think I've actually held a 13 inch
MacBook Pro this is nice physics unit is
incredible for screen real estate but
you do forget how large that thing is in
comparison to this little this is nice
it shocks me every single time
the keyboard I don't have one to do a
comparison to the previous version
because this is my first 13-inch MacBook
it's so light let's do a quick setup see
what else is in the box
USBC cable like always for charging some
instructional instructions and our power
brake instructional instructions for
instruction which contains a built-in
screen reader called voiceover to learn
how to voiceover I don't have your Mac
recipes Shh
Oh oh my god I touch the screen okay so
while this is connecting I'm going to
fully max out one of these and see what
you guys can get a 2.3 gigahertz
quad-core test gen 32 gigs of ram 4
terabyte of storage that will run you 35
and 99 oh we're ready it's still so
crazy how light it is in comparison to
the 16 inch cuz I'm so were used to
lugging that thing around
but it's great I also have the latest
MacBook Air as well today I'm gonna see
a size comparison next to that the back
will there also comes in gold so if you
were really set on getting a gold
MacBook that's it's really your only
option they are very very similar in
size the MacBook Air is slightly thinner
so what is interesting that was
comparing the $12.99 MacBook Air she
would be $12.99 MacBook Pro here's the
13-inch so you're gonna get the 8th gen
1.4 gigahertz core i5 whereas the
MacBook Air you're getting the 1.1
gigahertz quad core but with the 10th
gen Intel Core i5 processor so it's
interesting looking at those
side-by-side the MacBook Air you get
double the storage a little bit slower
processor but they are very similar it's
crazy because there's so many different
options right now that I do realize that
it is overwhelming then throw the iPad
pro into the mix now with that magic
keyboard again it just comes down to
what your plans are with this device
what is your lifestyle like and
hopefully that'll help make your
decision looking at these guys
side-by-side the MacBook Pro does give
you way more flexibility if you are
doing higher processor intensive things
like doing video editing or production
this has way more upgradable options
than the
okay so the higher end 10th gen models
do have four Thunderbolt 3 USB ports
whereas the lower end with the 8th gen
processors only have 2 so it's also
something to keep in mind when you are
trying to figure out which a laptop to
get you can also use the 13 intention on
a pro display xgr
it'll support one external 6k display
monitor one external 5k and up to two
external 4k displays another comparison
I want to do is the lowest end 16 inch
MacBook Pro in paracin to the highest
end base model MacBook Pro 13 inch so
this is the almost 2 fully maxed out 16
inch MacBook Pro and this thing is it's
a workhorse so here's the 13 inch
MacBook Pro all my goodness it's so cool
this is insane like is this the right
computer is this really this much
smaller I mean that's a significant size
difference I feel like my Animal
Crossing character when I use the
shocked reaction I need to clean it
because I'm disgusting this will have a
nice side-by-side clean screen
comparison ok is there like a macbook
carwash that i could take this thing
through the 16 inch macbook pro has a
starting price at 23 99 the 2.6 gave her
six core ninth Gen Intel Core i7
processor with a turbo boost up to four
point five gigahertz 16 gigs of ram 512
gigs of storage and four Thunderbolt 3
ports whereas the 13-inch is a to bigger
Hertz quad-core 10th Gen Intel Core i5
with a turbo boost up to three point
eight two guards 16 gigs of ram one
terabyte of storage and also for
Thunderbolt three ports for $19.99 so
the first thing obviously that you're
going to notice is the screen size the
16 inch is much larger the trackpad is
also way bigger over here on the 16 inch
the keyboard though is the new magic
keyboards it is great I'm a huge fan of
it although I am one of the few that did
like the butterfly keyboard I had no
problems with my keyboard at all and
they did now update back to the magic
keyboard I don't really
what it was like before back with a
butterfly keys because I've become quite
accustomed to this and I really like it
now I think we should take this back
there and plug it into the pro display
just so we can see just something good
to see what it looks like
it's so small it's just a weird after
having the 16 years of MacBook over here
prepare for the moment we've all been
waiting for
it's also great because the protis layer
will charge your MacBook so you don't
have to have any extra cables or cords
to charge it but here's the content you
guys are really here for yes what we are
making it animal crossing video it's
been a while I actually vomited she made
me these lamps and then I customized
them and then she's prepping you this
little Pisces way which is we're so it
works looks really good I mean it's a
six thousand dollar monitor so better
look good this is so light I love it
that's also a huge factor that you guys
need to consider is size this is so much
smaller than that 16 inch but you are
sacrificing some power for portability I
will keep stressing this in every single
video that I do it comes down to what
you actually do need and what you're
gonna do with this computer for me 16
inch MacBook Pro it is absolutely
perfect for everything I need on the
other hand if this 13 inch MacBook Pro
was the computer that I had I still feel
like I would be able to do a solid job
of video editing and making my
thumbnails and doing everything that I
needed to do to make youtube videos so
that was just a first look here at the
new 20 2013 inch macbook pro i'm
definitely excited to test this out more
and I would love to do a side-by-side
comparison to all the Mac's that I do
currently have so I have the MacBook Air
the 16 inch MacBook and of course the 13
inch so if that's something that you
guys would be interested in seeing I
would love to do a photo and video test
since that's basically what I use it for
let me know in the comments below and
now I'm gonna just continue testing this
out
so see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]